because you don't mess with success we
hate to say it but we're disappointed in
you Bucky you're supposed to be a leader
but you run and hide whenever things get
spooky we thought you had put your
zombie bullying days behind you but you
were back to the same old shenanigans
and zombies - you might have allowed
zombies to join your cheer squad but
that hasn't stopped you from sabotaging
and segregating them we know you're a
nice guy deep down Bucky but we're still
waiting for you to prove it zombies -
welcome to a brand new soundtrack and a
band of unique actors to the franchise
with so much going on it was easy to
miss out on some fun tidbits and
background information we're about to
dive into zombies - and reveal the 15
things everyone missed if you haven't
seen the sequel yet keep in mind that
this video contains some major spoilers
you've been warned
I'm sorry we got this is the first song
we hear in zombies - Addison and the
cheerleaders sing it while completing a
huge obstacle course at cheer camp and
Zed and the zombie friends join in while
dancing through zombie town but if you
hit pause ones head and the zombies are
dancing in front of the movie theater
you can see that night of the werewolf
is playing at the cinema is this a
coincidence probably not
what's even more curious however is that
the sign next to it is blurred out could
this be the title of zombies 3 watch
until the end to find out I'm so excited
to see well Zed's little sister Zoe
loves animals more than anything so we
weren't surprised that she was excited
about the werewolf threat instead of
being afraid
Zoe even put up a poster saying that she
wanted a werewolf friend that's when Zoe
crossed paths with Wyatt who was posing
as a human after chatting with Wyatt
Zoe realizes that he's not who he's
pretending to be Zoe makes remark about
the size of Wyatts eyes which look huge
behind his glasses Zoe says what big
eyes you have which is a reference to
the European fairy tale Little Red
Riding Hood if you noticed this
reference leave a wolf emoji in the
comments it's no secret that Bucky
doesn't like zombies he's made that very
clear but during the musical number we
got this we see just how far Bucky will
go to humiliate and harm the zombies at
his school
in a blink and you'll miss it moment we
see Bucky blasting a Z Team cheerleader
with his bug-zooka which is like a
bazooka but with water
we knew that Bucky was mischievous but
we never thought he would physically
harm his cheerleaders the look on the Z
team's faces says it all Bucky had a
bug-zooka made to sabotage the Z team
but they won anyway
every sports team needs a mascot which
is why no one batted an eye at the
Seabrook high mascot shrimpie but things
get a little weird when it was revealed
that shrimpy also doubled as a bus
driver clearly shrimpy had some issues
keeping his eyes and bus on the road
instead of slamming on the brakes when
he saw Zed on the ladder he hit the
zombie and kept driving
shrimpie did not stop driving until the
bus collided with a fence in the
Forbidden Forest so basically without
shrimpie
the werewolf's would never have seen
Addison and entered Seabrook without
shrimpy zombies - would not have been
possible trim peas days as a bus driver
are numbered he put everyone's lives at
risk when he failed to bring the bus to
a stop during his rampage we see
shrimpie collide with a fence and on the
fence is a sign that reads Forbidden
Forest keep out afterwards we find out
that this fence was stopping the
werewolves from getting outs for the
zombies and humans from getting in but
did you notice how small this fence was
what was stopping the almighty
werewolves from jumping over the fence
before shrimpie took it down and who put
up the fence in the first place there's
a lot of mystery surrounding the
Forbidden Forest and we're hoping to
find out more about it should the
franchise add a third installment did
any of you notice how huge the moon was
when Willa and her pack surrounded
Addison in the forest not only is the
moon huge and dark but it's also present
despite it being light outside could
this a bizarre moon be what powers the
moonstone in the first place and why can
this moon only be seen in the Forbidden
Forest
obviously Seabrook is a town unlike any
other so anything is possible anyway who
cares what they think
it's a terrible town
ever since zombie town was allowed to
open its gates tons of new shops have
popped up all over town there's the
Night of the Living Dead store and a
crystal shop to Seabrook has come a long
way since the first zombies movie but
they still have a long way to go
after watching zombies too we know that
the zombies and werewolves inherited
their special powers from magical
crystals
however Crystal shops are usually run by
witches could this crystal shop be
hinting towards Amba stry introducing
the witches of some sorts what other new
stores did you spot in zombie town and
Seabrook tell us in the comments the dog
ate my homework is one of the oldest
excuses in the book it's a joke that's
been used plenty of times and it popped
up in zombies too in the most subtle of
ways when Wyatt is following Addison in
the library the camera jumps to Bree who
is doing your homework but then winter
pops up behind her rips out a page from
her binder and eats it now we all know
that winter can go a little overboard
with her intimidation tactics but who
eats paper well a dog does we hope Brees
teacher believes her when she says that
[Music]
fan to the first zombies film were quick
to point out that the zombies all had
the letter Z in their names while some
zombies like the Zed and Zoe start their
names off with the letter others like
Eliza and Bonzo simply have a Z inside
of their first names well in case you
didn't notice the werewolves follow a
similar naming pattern as the zombies
Wyatts Willa and winter all have names
that start with the letter W but the
first letter of their names isn't the
only thing that can be linked back to
their werewolf backgrounds Willa and
Wyatt's last name is like Henson which
derives from the word Lycan and Lycan is
a term used to describe a humanoid wolf
it's pretty common for high schools to
have huge budgets when it comes to
sports but see Brooks cheerleading
budget is out of this world not only is
the town about to knock down Seabrook
power to make room for a new
cheerleading platform but it also hosts
a yearly cheer camp the obstacle course
we see during the song we gothis must
have cost the town thousands of
elders to build if not more Seabrook
High has a huge budget when it comes to
cheerleading every adult knows that they
have to watch what they say around
children kids can easily pick up on bad
words and repeat them without fail we
saw this happen when Addison was brought
to the den of the wolf when Addison is
attempting to howl she says a bunch of
hilarious things but at one point why it
stops her to remind her that there are
we're pups around winter points out that
Addison needs to put a pebble in the
swear wolf jar but the damage has been
done all of the young wolves mimic
Addison's swear word at the exact same
time did you catch this hilarious joke
she needs to put a pebble in the swear
wolf jar that and Bucky go head-to-head
for the chance to become the school
president they sing the catchy song I'm
winning to show the crowd why they
deserve to win during the song things
get a little personal
Bucky points out that Zedd is a monster
who can't control himself
Bucky believes this to be the reason why
he should be elected school president
instead of Zedd bud Zedd fires back
without a second to waste when Bucky
points out that Zedd eats brains Zedd
says that Bucky has nothing to worry
about since he has none zette called
Bucky stupid to his face and it flew
right over his head did you catch this
hilarious insult there's both good and
bad karma depending on what you put out
in the world
unfortunately for Zedd he did something
bad and received a huge dose of karma
within minutes when Zedd finds out that
Addison might be a werewolf he steals
her necklace to stop her from
transforming but obviously this wasn't
his choice to make
after winning over the crowd during the
presidential debate Zed's Zi ban clashes
with the crystal necklace which results
in said going full zombie on the crowd
because of this Zedd loses the crowd and
Bucky becomes the student body president
if Zedd hadn't stolen Addison's necklace
he might have won against Bucky I lost
the election
[Music]
the werewolf's might look like high
school students hence why they were
welcomed to join Seabrook hi
but these sly wolves are not who they
appear to be Willa
Wyatt winter and their pack are a lot
older than Addison Z & Company they
don't age like zombies and humans do at
the beginning of the movie winter says
that once they locate the moonstone
they'll be able to live Wolf's strong
for another 100 years
turns out the moonstone also provides
anti-aging properties and what do we do
we can recharge our necklaces and stay
wolf strong for another 100 years if you
thought the zombies franchise was over
and done with think again
although the Disney Channel has yet to
confirm a three pole it's obvious that
something is in the works
after all zombies too did end with a
cliffhanger we still don't know which
group Addison belongs to she's not a
human or a zombie or a werewolf if we
had to guess zombies three would finally
reveal Addison's true heritage Addison's
white hair was glowing bright blue at
the end of the sequel and a blue meteor
was seen falling from the sky there's so
much left to the story and we can't wait
to find out which new couples linked up
in Z 3 did anyone else notice the
chemistry between Eliza and Wyatt sound
off in the comments thanks for watching
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up for more we'll see
you soon